it's like is it another level there's a
giant man he goes he was playing a
zombie in a TV show I did call Death
Valley they said you can kick me here
just really kick me cuz I'm gonna be
bent over I go okay
and I go but I don't wanna kick guitar
he goes he goes look at me goes you can
kick me real hard
I gotta go and I had the call saying as
I go I said this out loud no I did I go
I go I'm a black belt in Taekwondo and
he looked at me because it's cool dude I
get it I'm sure you are I first think I
kick him and then he goes I'm telling
you that Sega I [ __ ] kick him no but
ever he was he was just fine you give me
fights growing up Rob oh yeah
let me does that when I look at you I
think Street Fighter yeah that's just
survival ya know but the thing is you
guys didn't know but that you had to be
when you're smaller and also when you're
also you know it's like you got to get
it over with quick the fight either win
or lose quickly and also make sure it's
in front of as many people so there's a
chance of somebody to break it up yeah
that's not close to the school make sure
there's an adult that could be within
the area yeah I had to strategize the
whole time and it was like I remember
like one time it was Bill Schulz his
brother John Schultz I remember he you
know there's something wrong with that
family god bless him but like and I
remember this one kid and I said just
keep the fight close to the school and
sure enough he waited for me to get far
enough away from the school and this is
a knock-down drag-out fight until we're
both exhausted and I had a big gigantic
black eye and they smell like how hard
some kids had hard hands yeah some kids
you could take it some kids like I
remember like cliff vanderwerff damn you
remember the name yeah oh we could never
hit like my friend Rick Gloucester was
my best buddies we're still going
where'd you grow up
just right below San Francisco I grew up
in the Haight Ashbury the Summer of Love
was the summer of moving for us Summer
of Love I swear if we were that was at
born 1963 1967 there's like you know you
had like yeah yeah you know yeah the
whole yeah that my dad actually know
treats there's a bunch of crazy hippies
out there but then we move down to the
but I basically I grew up in mom was
Filipino right yeah in Pacifica so yeah
so but a baby was a cliff renderer
him his in my friend Rick said yeah how
I look is that you're okay but your nose
is over here but so you know and like
there's an about McPeake I remember
that's a big dude I remember this guy I
just gotta wait wait get him right in
the nose
do you remember the nose you see if I
pop in the nose it's over cuz then you
can't see then it's really over it's not
gonna nose you if you gotta really want
to fight after getting hit in the nose
not me maybe you remember details like
that you know remembers nice I don't
have any details my child is a complete
blur a little blurred
yeah my my friend said to me my buddy
goes ah you're not known you your whole
life I know nothing about your childhood
yeah sometimes I wonder about it
sometimes I wonder because we're getting
older is it that or but you I don't know
I just don't memory I just never think
about my childhood that way I remember
some names but not that's you remember
negative times lunch - no but I mean a
couple of fights that I win it's not as
interesting cuz yeah you know let it eat
you up yeah
but I remember like I just this one guy
really wanted to fight me and I was
avoiding it but I made sure I stayed on
the school grounds I was walking around
the school and literally like at that
time there was hundreds of kids I'm not
exaggerating they were just waiting for
anything to break the tedium they're so
bored it's happening yeah yeah and so I
just anyway so he just he just came at
me and I couldn't back the way anymore
cuz there was a little bit crowd behind
me said okay here we go and then and
then I never wanted to fight though cuz
I for me I remember kid said I'll see
you after school and for me I was always
the kid at school who like I like
everybody
my my it's just I like everybody and I
wanna like me and the last thing I want
do is fight I'd it's not in my thing
yeah and I remember he was big and
strong and I was probably in eighth
grade and I was like number one I don't
want to fight that guy's gonna beat me
up number two it makes me feel bad oh
yeah number three I'm [ __ ] scared if
you feel when I was bombed by took is
you have to like it's that thing is your
life's in danger like you mean for
professional either yeah it's like you
can't let me I don't want to hit that
guy's totally yeah I bet I don't wanna
hit this guy too hard then you can't
fight anymore right yeah well my thing
is I had an older brother who's the
scariest guy in the neighborhood so if I
was having a problem I knew I was gonna
fight it out till my friend like we just
come we just think a week come so if you
got out
and bigbro was there yeah well I I knew
I wouldn't get my ass whipped that bad
cuz he would jump he need somebody at
least in he was now he's like I want to
get kicked in the head
you guys are like beating on other
people there's one who thought
psychopath yes there was one psycho his
older brother Tony Tony Lewis was it was
the older brother all the names Mike Joe
Louis was the younger guy my age who was
just you know like a man at 13 yeah like
his side Bernie roids because hey I had
to hunt and this guy and he just wanted
to beat the [ __ ] out everybody just was
like I want him he said come on you
could probably beat my ass you know what
you could probably I was like I knew oh
you're good and I'm good I don't need to
I'm good they say in jail even in jail
like where did the bat is Chronos oh
yeah it's a very small fraction of
people that are actual Psychopaths and
super violent but they're the ones that
control everything so a lot of times in
jail you'll see like they'll have you
know people get stabbed and stuff
that shit's being controlled by a very
small group of dudes and sometimes
they'll have these programs will I take
those guys and just put them in take
your same 8:01 you have a real those
people in jail you wanna do the tiny
that's what I get along they're actually
hanging out and stuff like that
it's the sociopaths at the top that that
organize and enforce stuff like they did
sound frickin gentles the same thing but
at least they're in jail it's a
sociopath outside of jail you worried
yeah that's the problem
yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue Oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]